you know my friend i've been put in a
similar situation before too
where i was chilling with some home so
this is what i'm like
17 18. yeah by then you know i'm just my
focus is i'm trying to get to college
you know i'm just trying to like go down
a straight path not not get into any
trouble
i'm hanging out and um a group of maybe
like 15 dudes
walk uh walk into where we're hanging
out at it's it's outdoor area outdoor
seating right and there's there's like
two islands right so i'm sitting on one
side and then this other group of guys
come in and then they sit on the other
side pretty a good amount of distance
between us
and then i just kind of look at them and
then i'm like ah you know these dudes
kind of look like you know they're up to
no good yeah but it doesn't really
matter right
so i don't really think anything of it
and then maybe about like 15 minutes
later like me and my homies are just
sitting and talking
um and mind you most of these guys that
i'm with
are not never were really involved in
that type of stuff
they're good guys you know one other
homie
was you know yeah but
two girls walk by walk by our table
they're pretty cute
they walk by this way and then and then
stop
like little bit past our table and then
start walking back
i was like all right that's kind of
weird i thought they were like going
somewhere
you know maybe to the bathroom or to a
store or whatever
and then they're cute so i say what's up
right
i just say what's up and then they look
and they smile at me so i'm like oh cool
and then i just go back to talking with
my homies
uh maybe not a minute later i start to
see
like five dudes starting to walk over to
our area yeah
and then i it catches my i see it from
the corner of my eye so i i turn my head
and i look
and then they're walking over and
they're dogging me
and i get [ __ ] irritated you know
like
i don't think i i still had that
maturity to check my
my uh emotions yeah like what the [ __ ]
you looking at man yeah
i said that to him right what the [ __ ]
you say
vietnamese guy yeah i said what the [ __ ]
you looking at you know
walks over and then uh he gets in my
face so i get up
and then um his other homies who
came with him they stand behind
uh the friends that i'm with my now the
friends that i'm with have their back
turned to them
oh [ __ ] they're standing behind them i
see these fools pull out shanks and then
put it under their shirt like this
so this guy who's coming up to here to
me
is sitting here [ __ ] just talking
[ __ ] to my face
right meanwhile i'm just looking
at those dudes yeah and then i'm like
i i swear to god this felt like a
[ __ ] eternity yeah
it was maybe like a minute two minute
long and so i'm like what the [ __ ]
like i wanna [ __ ] like bank this dude
right i'ma [ __ ] this dude up but as soon
as i punch this dude
my homies are gonna get stabbed yeah so
all these thoughts are running through
my head like
i'm like dude what what do i [ __ ] do
you know that gives me anxiety
no for sure so i'm thinking like oh [ __ ]
if they get stabbed their parents are
gonna [ __ ] have to you know go get
him at the hospital maybe they're gonna
die like what
because because i can't and then this
dude shoved me
right that's when i was i made a face
that i was
like oh you [ __ ] yeah and then my
other homie gets up out of his seat too
you know and and this is the only one
other homie who's like you know
who's kind of from that same background
yeah so he was down
right but then i still am in the
predicament i'm like what the [ __ ] do i
do here yeah
um and then the only thing that [ __ ]
say i couldn't i couldn't take action i
was like paralyzed you know i had a fist
i was
[ __ ] angry but then i'm like these
dudes are gonna [ __ ]
as soon as i punch him boom boom yeah
you know like from the back that's it
yeah luckily thank [ __ ] god
cop showed up oh [ __ ] yeah that's the
only [ __ ] time i was
glad to see five [ __ ] only time in my
[ __ ] life
cops show up what's going on here and
i'm like
yeah i'm not an officer we're just you
know we're just all friends we're just
talking you know oh man i would have
snitched
so fast doc i would have been the
biggest snitch ever on my officer
those men have knives and they're trying
to assault me
that's i was just like oh you know
nothing's going on officer you know
we're just all friends we're just
talking you know we're just hanging out
um he's like you sure nothing's going on
here it's like nah it's cool dogs i
would have been blinking yes
obviously nothing's going on i would
have blinked my eyes super hard
what's wrong with your eyes son you need
to [ __ ] see this [ __ ]
you see yeah i would have been like
um and then so uh
after that happened those guys uh
left right they went back to the other
side
now little did they know there was
actually another table
um of group of guys that we knew and
they saw [ __ ] was going down too
and they had bottles on them so they
were starting to pour out their drinks
ready to [ __ ] hit the guys who were
standing behind my friends they're
behind those guys
and so it was just like this just
[ __ ] cluster [ __ ] of a situation you
know
and all of it would have triggered with
me throwing that punch yeah and the guy
who came up to me
he never like punched me he just kept
pushing me right
he wanted you to do yeah he wanted me to
yeah exactly he want he was instigating
and and like i was like ah thank [ __ ]
god like
that that situation kind of died the way
it died
and then i saw five minutes later those
dudes bounced yeah and i was like you
know what
we should get the [ __ ] out of here too
let's leave right
so we leave um after we leave from the
parking lot
maybe about 10 minutes later my homie
calls me he's like
hey you guys left for sure right and i
was like yeah why what's up
he's like i just came to get some gas
and those guys are at the gas station
oh i don't think they recognize me but i
hear them over talking they're telling
like they're calling their friends to
bring guns and they're gonna go back
there
god damn you know so like if if we stuck
around
they probably would have lit us up you
know you should have just told the cop
they have weapons on them officer
and i am a good christian boy dog i
would have snitched so
fast dude you know i'm not about that
life i'm like [ __ ]
i would have been crying no but the
thing is though it's like you know
kind of it's like if if you have an
exchange of words
you got to be ready for it to you know
get to that level
right um i mean i've had friends get
stabbed from trying to stop a fight
yeah you know because [ __ ] pops off and
they're trying to get in the middle and
they get stabbed you know
so it's like you can't you can't be
around
that type of environment that type of
people even if you're like the most
peaceful dude
oh 100 right and not expect something to
happen
and so like i think i told you the story
too like once i got into college
and then i would connect with some of
these you know friends or whatever
like one time we're hanging out in front
of a
you know dude's driveway just kicking it
cars driving by everybody's acting a
little bit weird every time a car drives
by like a little bit you know kind of
fidgety
i'm like yo man the [ __ ] is going on is
there something i should know about like
you guys are acting weird every time a
car is driving by
like you know just let's just say get
ready to duck and roll
so i get the phone yeah i'm like nah i'm
good on that man
i'm in college now you know i don't need
that [ __ ] i just [ __ ] left you know
but i think like that's the thing too
when uh
it's weird like when i hear these
stories like i you know i go back to
that moment where i'm just like this
young little goofy kid
and i see that dude get his [ __ ] air
force one spit on
and then [ __ ] a bunch of dudes stand
up and they're all strapped and i'm like
what the [ __ ] you know and i remember
too like in that moment
what it felt like i could kind of feel
it now i was scared
it those moments where you feel like
you're going to die feel like a
[ __ ] eternity yeah that i think that
altercation
had to be at most maybe 40 seconds right
40 seconds to a minute
relax right that [ __ ] felt like 20
minutes sure when you're
when when when [ __ ] is